hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Jackie who is an
entrepreneur who has connections in
China with manufacturing companies so
he's in China and he wants to create
handbags and export them to the United
States Canada Australia and other
markets so he's asking for my advice on
how to find people to partner with in
those markets be able to sell his
products so it's a great opportunity
Jackie from talking to Canadian
entrepreneurs is a Canadians perspective
there's a number of companies who work
with Chinese manufacturers and have
difficulty with timelines and managing
the culture differences so if you were
running a professional operation and can
help kind of smooth those relations then
it could be a really good opportunity if
you're looking at partnering up I would
suggest trying to find a company who's
already in the business of selling
handbags so either look for somebody
who's creating their own handbags and
may not be happy with their provider
their supplier it could be an
opportunity for you to come in and maybe
start with a small project and expand
from there or look for somebody who's
already in the business maybe selling it
in the retail operation selling other
bags and are looking to potentially
create their own and that could be an
opportunity to come in and help them
with that product line I think that's
probably the best option instead of
looking for a new designer or a startup
company you ideally want somebody who
already has a way to sell the product so
they have a customer base it makes their
chance at success a lot higher and your
chance at success a lot higher you could
gamble on a start-up but the chances of
them being successful are pretty low
compared to someone who already has an
established customer base so I try to
reach out to those companies do some
research find some of those companies
introduce yourself start with some
samples start with a small project
hopefully it works out you can build the
relationship and move on to bigger and
bigger products so I hope that helps
Jackie for everybody else if you enjoyed
the video please give it a thumbs up I
always love seeing your thumbs ups and
if you also want to leave some feedback
on what you thought about the video as a
comment I'd love to hear from you as
well stay tuned and I will see in the
next episode
you